yeah it's been amazing for me to be able
to work you know wisdom medicines
because you know since I got on this
path when I was 16 I was you know
interested in psychotherapy and then
interested in an ordinary states of
consciousness but they were kind of like
two separates part of my life and you
know sometimes I referred my clients to
holotropic breathwork and work with an
ordinary state and so now the
possibility of you know having those two
together and you know seeing the
possible benefits and transformation for
clients it has been really wonderful you
know and I even you know was the
ketamine we work with people with
depression anxiety post-traumatic stress
disorder and other issues and it seems
like it's it's a you know really
supportive and transformational work
that we can see for many people in my
shorter period of time than traditional
talk therapy so I've been very grateful
and just amazed at the possibilities
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake Owen
we are still a consciousness hackings a
week in future summit we are now talking
to Veronica Gold hello hi thank you so
much for coming on the show really
appreciate it yeah so glad you have me
thank you
we're really excited Veronica is the
co-founder of polar is insight and you
can find that link in the bio Polar's
insight calm Veronica teach us about who
you are and what you represent so I'm a
psychotherapist and specializes trauma
therapist and I work on the MDMA PTSD
psych assisted psychotherapy study for
maps and I'm a co-founder and therapists
and Polaris insight Center where we
provide ketamine assisted psychotherapy
whoa okay so okay so the current the
currently the MDMA SSI closed era P is
doing really well it's now going to
phase three exactly we are we have
started phase three around the world in
different sites exactly around the
United States and three sites outside of
the US and
you know it's going really well it has
got a designation of a breakthrough
therapy by FDA and so we're hoping that
there is now going and approval for
compassionate use program so that MDMA
would be available for people for
treatment of PTSD before it is
rescheduled before the end of the phase
3 whoa okay and then the there's
profound benefits that are already
happening was the numbers are like about
two-thirds of people are feeling like
exactly yeah and then there is as well
we're seeing from the face too that
people continue to improve so not only
in the end of the study there's still
some people who benefit even like a year
after that they you know it's out of
therapy once the therapy is finished and
so we're you know excited and curious to
see the results in the phase 3 well okay
so what has it been like being a
psychotherapist with people that have
been going through and this is not only
Thunda me but also you said with
ketamine - yeah exactly and so you know
working on the under study and starting
to work with patients in the in the way
with non-ordinary states of
consciousness we are working on it and
waiting for the rescheduling and
expanded access but then the possibility
of working with ketamine has been here
because that allows to work with the
non-ordinary states and healing of
trauma anxiety depression already now
because it's a Schedule three drug and
so we started hilarious to provide
ketamine assisted psychotherapy and be
able to support people in legal wave as
the medicines in the United States now
Polaris in sight yes yes okay now polar
is inside Polaris right yeah it's like
the star like a desert like tomato
tomahto
okay Polaris insight they're like a star
okay okay so alright so then the some of
the benefits that you've already been
seeing are the integration the of the
traumatic experiences so teach us about
what this has been like for us
psychotherapists
walls for the patient's themselves that
are going it's been amazing for me to be
able to work you know wisdom medicines
because you know since I got on this
path but I was 16 I was you know
interested in psychotherapy and then
interested in an ordinary states of
consciousness but they were kind of like
two separates part of my life and you
know sometimes I referred my clients to
holotropic breathwork and work with an
ordinary state and so now the
possibility of you know having those two
together and you know seeing the
possible benefits and transformation for
clients it has been really wonderful you
know and I even you know was the
ketamine we work with people with
depression anxiety post-traumatic stress
disorder and other issues and it seems
like it's it's a you know really
supportive and transformational work
that we can see for many people in my
shorter period of time than traditional
talk therapy so I've been very grateful
and just amazed at the possibilities the
efficacy is increasing from talk therapy
to psychedelic psychotherapy to even
being able to do things with the bio
signals that we're getting from the
brain and the body yeah so it's just
like the constant upgrading of what of
what we can do with these persistent non
symbolic states of consciousness okay so
then what's going on with ketamine as
well because where is they were they in
terms of their ability to to use
ketamine around the world yeah so you
know one thing I want to point out is
kind of like that this you know ketamine
or mdma-assisted therapy that the drug
and the medicine session is just part of
the treatment so people are you know
coming for talk therapy as a preparation
and integration of the session so that
is the whole treatment and ketamine is
legally prescribed in many countries
around the world in the United States
the Schedule three drug it
is approved for anesthesia so for any
psychiatric treatment its off-label use
medicine and a lot of clinical trials
have been done with treatment of
depression but these trials are really
only using the drug for its medicinal
properties
you know kind of the the effect on the
brain on the body but we are looking at
using you know having benefit of that
but as much as dead is the benefit of
the therapy that we do while the person
is you know under the effect of the
ketamine
so the assisted psychotherapy part is a
really key component of the healing yes
and you know taking the principles that
we share is the mdma-assisted
psychotherapy of you know trusting the
inner healing intelligence that comes
through in an unordinary state of
consciousness and this nonlinear way of
healing healing through experience so
that like i know when you mentioned the
trauma that you know people can you know
traumas can come up in a different way
and can have different experience in
relating to what is coming out and with
the support of the medicine and the
therapists to actually heal and
integrate what happened yes yes and so
talk therapies is still a part of this
process at the beginning and at the end
both okay okay but then usually talk
therapy doesn't have a psychedelic
experience in the middle so that's the
new edition okay okay and then and then
when something comes up in the in during
the the psychedelic experience then
there is a psychotherapist there to help
them get through what that is what's
happening yeah so how we work is that we
are was the client for the whole time of
the treatment so the ketamine assisted
psychotherapy session in Polaris there's
three hours long and so the person comes
in you know and we are with them for
that whole time so when you know they
take the medicine and some things come
up we are there to you know from
anything to just provide safety you know
write down some saying what they want us
to
you know write down and we can come back
to or process something what's coming up
to their mind there is this kind of
inward and outward parts of the session
so their time for the session when the
person can go inward and is more in
silence in the inner process but in
their coming out and sharing with us you
know what they are experiencing what
they experience so the very start of
this dance between our inner and our
focus during the session whoa
and then does it with with ketamine then
what is occurring the physiologically
within the body and neuro scientifically
when it's administered yeah so they're
you know different ways of people trying
to understand what exactly happens and
we actually don't know what exactly
happens there is the glutamate pathways
where you know it affects the brain
there is a it's there is a increased
neuroplasticity by increased
communication and the pyramid cells in
the brain and so that of like when you
think about neurons and people visit
depression the neurons kind of stop
connecting with each other and there is
more of like a shutdown mode in the
brain so the ketamine kind of increases
like it grows and interaction of the
neurons so there is more connectivity
and new per new prospects are being
built so it actually changes the
physiology the activation in the brain
neuroplasticity and that allows people
to make new changes may have new
insights and create more lasting changes
in their life as well you know I think
there is more when the medicine does in
the body but there is you know just
different conversations and ideas how
exactly it works
there is the dissociative effect of the
medicine the ketamine is classified as
dissociative anesthetic and so the
dissociation is kind of coming out of
the body so person can have out-of-body
experience which allows them you know to
have kind of a distance view on what is
going on in their life
of separation as well oftentimes feeling
of belonging with something greater than
them so that allows them to feel more
you know trust and peace into whatever
they're working with and as well they
have there has been studies that show
that the greater the dissociation the
greater the antidepressant effect and
you know in that we can talk about like
the dissociation as well as the
possibility of mystical experience that
correlates with the antidepressant
effectiveness of the medicine okay the
more mystical T experienced more
antidepressant today's yeah and says
it's you know it's it's a beautiful
finding in ways that you know like there
is a difference between dissociate like
so sometimes people said I could have
Nate when they have trauma they
dissociate they kind of like blank out
or they're a very Spacey II or day it's
a way of managing what happened to them
and so the ketamine they're saying like
well how kind of ketamine hell when
ketamine is dissociative so it's
somebody who dissociates how is the
dissociation going to happen but it's
it's help it's a different type of
dissociation so the you know the first
time when somebody is overwhelmed and
dissociates it's like a body's way of a
reset of kind of helping the person like
not to feel what's overwhelming while
the ketamine is there's like physical
dissociation of the body which actually
creates this space but a person can
still be connected and aware of what is
happening so it it actually works well
for some people who dissociate it
actually it's almost like it dissociates
them from this protective part of them
which dissociate so as almost like two
minuses and suddenly the person feels
more embodied and have greater access to
the thing they need to talk about our
process mm-hmm okay okay and then
they're usually talking through the
process with you or another
psychotherapist definitely so as well
depends on the dosage so a lower dosage
there is more conversation if we work
with higher dosage there
might be more inner focus and then there
is more talk and processing as the
medicine is wearing off so that you know
it's it's kind of very individualized we
are looking at why the person is coming
in what they're struggling with what is
their hope and intention for the
treatment what is their prior experience
with medicines and psychedelics what is
their sensitivity and then kind of work
with different dosages of the medicine
and so lower the medicine there's more
of just like psycholytic Trump's effect
where people are likely to converse more
as we go higher there is more of this
dissociative effect where people go more
inward and as then the medicine is
wearing off they they share more so what
are your thoughts on the next sort of
steps with the flourishing of
psychedelic psychotherapy around the
planet where are we where are we heading
are we heading to smaller like clinics
popping up around the world is that kind
of the idea yeah there is different you
know it's a great question and I'm
asking myself all the time how that can
look like and you know I think there is
this really desire and seeing the
potential of this transformation and as
well the importance to know that it is
one of the tools and that you know it's
not just a medicine that you say that
there is you know the therapy around
your lifestyle support and thinking
about it preparation integration and
staying with the values and the guiding
principles of this work so there is you
know attempt like can we just do a lot
of clinics or give someone the medicine
and they're gonna heal and thinking
about like what all is needed to really
do it in the most ethical way and that
you know the people who provide the
medicines have proper training continued
consultation and then you know opening
clinics and around the world and and you
know and that there is different needed
for someone who lives in the city they
might prefer a clinic in the city while
other people there will be more nature
settings that you know that they can
look in all different ways so I think
there is a lot of possibility
and a lot of conversations about how
that can look like how is mm-hmm
so some potentially in cities some
potentially nature do do you think all
of them have a component like does
Polaris have a component where they have
the and does the the current ones
happening through maps do we have the
component of audio and visual
stimulation as well during the
psychedelic experience yeah and so and
that's a you know thinking about what it
what are the guiding principles and you
know when we bring technology how can it
support the process and not interrupt
right and so there is this inner guiding
intelligence that the medicine allows
like what needs to come up to come up so
we don't want to kind of bring something
or direct where the person's gonna go so
I can see that a lot of the technologies
that we have can be and are being
developed can be really helpful in the
preparation in the integration and then
some during the sessions you know and
I'm think about like music and you know
we use music in all sessions sound
tables but as well like that it doesn't
interact with the natural way what a
person's going through so you know like
I've had colleagues who said like oh
there is you know these devices that can
help the person not to get to a place
where they are very distressed it like
prevents a bad tray and so it can sound
really good like oh the session can be
you know we can feel better but
sometimes we can see like well that
would interrupt the process maybe there
is something what a person needs to get
through and you know kind of intervening
in this way would actually stop their
process and prevent them from the actual
healing so we can see like what would be
helpful is there a way that like some
technologies can help the therapists to
know what is going on for the person is
there something that the therapist
doesn't know is there gonna be helpful
or is it going to take away from the
attune event to the patient so those are
you know good questions and
I definitely can see how technology can
be used in preparation and integration
and in some ways during the sessions
yeah in the way that it's personalized
to each person and what their
experiences have been what their like
current tastes and music is I'm
interested also to know what your
thoughts are on the is it well quick is
is Polaris physical location or is it
you guys mobile to get to people so we
have a clinic in Castro in San Francisco
clinic in chat so we have a actual
location awesome and then is and then is
there what what is Lee legally speaking
ketamine can be used for specific things
so it's off-label use for all
psychiatric diagnosis so all psychiatric
it so when it's used for healing yeah it
is off-label use because the FDA
approved used for ketamine is for
anesthesia it is a very safe anesthetic
but the doctor can prescribe it for
other use and you know kind of what
they're saying like if the body of of
same professionals would agree that it
is a good indication
so there are being studies done on
depression trauma anxiety addiction and
so it's not specifically approved for
those conditions but it has been used
and so if the doctor has a reasonable
indication for a person they can
prescribe it and then people can use it
but it's so off-label only in the case
of psychiatric purposes can be used
right and you know or for anything for
any like if the doctor decided there was
is some illness and that this would be
appropriate treatment they could
prescribe it but you need to have a
diagnosis so the medicine can be
prescribed but not no recreational use
of this so usually you know at this time
it is known it is a controlled substance
so controlled substance and only for
psychiatric purposes
okay okay so we don't have it for you
know consciousness exploration or
personal growth yes that you know could
be beneficial and people do experience
that when they're getting the treatment
but that isn't we don't have doctors
cannot prescribe for personal growth and
then a couple quick questions on the way
out are are we in a simulation good
questions what do you think we can't
read it is how how you think about it
how do you think about it yeah yeah I
mean it's a it's it's definitely a
possibility what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world I think
it's it's being alive being embodied and
you know connecting with each other
connecting with nature and I think
that's our purpose to be fully embodied
an experience you know and and livin in
now in this state of our planet is to
help each other and help the planet yeah
this has been such a wonderful
conversation Veronica thank you so much
for coming on the show and talking to us
thank you for having me really there's
still so much to unpack and understand
about the importance of what you do so
we hope to have more conversation about
this especially as the medicine
continues to proliferate around the
world and become free to use yes yes
huge thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate you'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below in
the episode also check out the link in
the bio to Polaris insight as well as
other links to Veronica and also have
more conversations your friends your
family your co-workers people online on
social media about the benefits of
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy and
also check out the links below to
consciousness hacking as well
simulations support the organizations
the entrepreneurs and the artists around
the world that you believe in and go and
build the future manifest your dreams
the world thank you so much for tuning
in and we will see you soon peace